[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new black panther to
marvel x-men video recently there was a
big Marvel interview talking about major
x-men characters in the movies so we'll
break it down and what it means for the
MCU and Marvel phase four and Marvel
phase five in terms of their big x-men
plans if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a bunch of big Marvel stuff
coming up really soon we'll do a new
Amazon giveaway - all you have to do to
enter it just be a subscriber and let me
know what you want to see from x-men
characters in black panther 2 so just
starting with number 5 recently in an
interview with Empire magazine Janelle
Monae actually revealed she had met with
Bryan Kugler about being in black
panther 2 and that she had spoken to him
about playing the storm character
implying that Marvel really is seriously
thinking about doing full-blown x-men
characters in the MCU movies as early as
Black Panther - even though there's been
a bunch of delays with the Marvel phase
4 movies in the Marvel phase 5 movies
black panther 2 is still supposed to
come out May 20-22
they have not moved that so clearly it's
one of their most important films that's
coming up but there's a lot to unpack
here in terms of x-men characters coming
into the MCU there have been a bunch of
high-profile actresses and celebrities
that have said they want to play major
x-men characters now that Marvel has the
rights back and because it's gonna be a
while before we see Avengers 5 black
panther 2 is just one of the most
high-profile projects they have coming
up so that's why so many of them are
talking about black panther - even the
Russo brothers were recently talking
about the new MCU version of Wolverine
and x-men characters they're actually
currently working on a film with Tom
Holland that they're releasing later
this year so obviously people are still
asking them a bunch of MCU questions
about x-men characters they said that
they still talk to Marvel about doing
new Marvel projects all the time but
they don't plan to come back to do
another Marvel movie for a good long
while but they will eventually come back
and do another Marvel film a lot of
people just feel like that's going to be
Marvel's rebooted x-men movie eventually
number 4 Janelle Monae revealed this big
black panther tube meeting that she had
with Marvel and Ryan Coogler actually
happened a while ago and she just kept
it secret while all this Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame stuff
was coming and going she says that she
was actually working on one of her new
albums at the same place where Ryan
Coogler and Marvel were polishing up
Black Panthers
so they just started to run into each
other casually and she'd been seeing all
the news about Marvel getting the x-men
characters back and had been standing
storm her entire life like you do storm
is a queen she said at the time she
wasn't any kind of Marvel insider or
anything she didn't know what their
Marvel phase 4 movie plans were going to
be for Black Panther character or a
black panther - and she didn't say
whether or not ryan coogler revealed
everything about his plans for black
panther - but Marvel only just announced
the movie and put a release date on it
back at d23 the reason why it's taking
them four years to release Black Panther
- even though it sounds like ryan
coogler has been making plans for black
panther - since the end of black panther
1 is just because of how far ahead
Marvel plans its movie phases and
because they had to go through a new
round of negotiations with Ryan Coogler
and his team to actually get them back
legally to write and direct Black
Panther - apparently they'd only signed
him in his people for the first Black
Panther movies so when it blew up and
made all that money it just gave them an
opportunity to push for more creative
control and a ton more money for the
sequels so don't be surprised if Marvel
actually built in an option for Black
Panther 3 when he re signed for Black
Panther - James Gunn kind of did the
same thing for the guardians of the
galaxy sequels like if they know a
director is good and they like them they
want to bring them back for future
sequels they'll build that into their
contracts so all that legal stuff and
the negotiations just added a whole
bunch of extra time to the development
process otherwise we probably would have
seen black panther - right after
spider-man far from home in the Black
Widow movie number 3 what's going on
with the new versions of the x-men
characters during Marvel phase 4 and
Marvel phase 5 well technically black
panther 2 is Marvel phase 5 because the
Marvel phase 4 movies right now are
supposed to end with Thor for love and
thunder / the announcement that they
made at Comic Con about the schedule
there were some dates that got shuffled
around because of the virus so Thor 4
isn't happening till a little bit later
now but technically it was planned to be
the end of Marvel phase 4 in the
transition to Marvel phase 5
they've been out several Marvel phase 5
movies since then these dates have
actually changed since they pushed some
of the movies but these are some of the
Marvel phase 5 movies black panther -
being one of them the Russos also did an
interview recently explaining the
reasons why we didn't see a bunch of big
x-men teasers in avengers endgame like a
big x-men post-credit scene because that
would have been a May
they said that it was all about the
timing of the Disney Fox deal and how
that conflicted with the development
process and filming of Avengers infinity
war in Avengers endgame so they wrote
the scripts and developed Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame at the
exact same time as if it were one giant
movie just split into a couple parts
remember the old title card when they
released that very first teaser I think
was back in 2014 like this is what it's
going to be Avengers infinity War part 1
and part 2 so they needed to know what
most of the story for everything was
going to be back in 2016 when they
officially hired the writers that's also
when they decided that they were gonna
change infinity war part 2 to be
avengers endgame and use a completely
different title there was a big
behind-the-scenes featurette they
released so in this conference room
where all of this concept art is they
had the walls plastered with a picture
from every single MCU character that
they had the rights to that they could
put in the movie that was still alive so
way back in 2016 the Fox Disney deal
hadn't even gotten started yet that
didn't really become a thing till 2018
and the deal didn't close until Avengers
end game was hitting theaters in spring
of 2019 Kevin Feige explained that
legally the Disney lawyers would not
allow him to have any big meetings about
x-men projects development or hire
anyone to write scripts or seriously
talk to the Russos about using those
characters and either Avengers infinity
war Avengers endgame in any way not even
verbal references a lot of people had
just held out hope that they'd pull a
big shwarma twist late in the game like
they did for the first Avengers movie if
you don't know the crazy story behind
how they did that shwarma scene Marvel
filmed the classic Avengers post-credit
scene right after the movie premiered
April 11th they screened the movie for
the first time for critics then
literally right after that put all the
actors in makeup and costumes and film
the scene so that they could add it to
the movie before it was released to the
rest of the public at the beginning of
May but number 2 the reason why Kevin
Feige said that we're not seeing a ton
of mutants right away in Marvel phase 4
movies like The Black Widow movie is
just because it takes a couple years to
develop their movies and they were
developing all these first Marvel phase
4 movies back when they didn't have the
rights to the x-men characters and
because when they do introduce the
characters they want to do them justice
they want to do it right
think about what
with x-men Dark Phoenix most people
still think of that when they think of
the x-men characters Marvel clearly
wants to let some time pass in the dust
to settle on that so the one they do
eventually announced that rebooted solo
x-men movie people aren't immediately
thinking of all that stuff you know uh
you know what that makes this a reunion
for x-men origins reunite yeah in there
a billion other new characters that they
have the rights to now like the
Fantastic Four characters who are in
dire need of a reboot in a good movie
for once so that's the main reason why
so many big actors have been talking
about X Men in Black Panther 2 because
by that time everyone feels like enough
time will have passed that you can
reintroduce new versions of some of
those characters the reason why storm is
being talked about so much for Black
Panther 2 it's just because of their
connection in the comics and they come
from similar backgrounds the tribe that
she comes from is relatively close to
what Conda in Africa and if you think
about Namor and Atlantis being here on
the Atlantic coast / Nick Fury's big
Easter Egg at the end of Iron Man two
storms tribe would be on the opposite
side of Wakanda from them storm is also
the queen of her tribe that she comes
from so she understands a lot of the
burdens that T'Challa carries in the
hard choices that he has to make protect
his people or protect the rest of the
world and if you're talking about s tier
waifu's storm is an omega-level mutant
one of the most powerful x-men
characters that there are so she just be
a really badass character to introduce
during Black Panther 2 there's also been
a lot of fantastic for rumors of some of
those characters being teased in Black
Panther 2 as well the Black Panther
character debuted in the comics for the
first time in the Fantastic Four so it
makes sense that they'd at least have
some Easter eggs for the Fantastic Four
in the movie even if they're not ready
to recast those actors yet
everyone's looking over at John
Krasinski there's been so much fan art
of him as mr. fantastic the past few
years but more recently he's just been
having fun on his YouTube show messin
with people this is the clip of him
talking about that this week a whole new
curveball was presented when I fell
face-first through the looking glass
into the what the actual heck is going
on world of fan art that's right for
someone who only just got off dial up
this week this whole internet thing
continues to be a
constant source of surprise and living
nightmares and finally there's this four
panel er which I have to appreciate and
it'll be the closest I ever get to
playing a comic-book hero everyone let
me know in the comments though what kind
of x-men and Fantastic Four Easter eggs
do you want to see in Black Panther 2
and who do you want to play some of
those characters I'll say
congratulations to Tim Vega you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here to watch Hugh
Jackman break down all the Wolverine
Marvel movies and click here for that
funny Marvel x-men reunion video thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]